whoa oh okay oh of course
ah man it was right in front of my face
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Fran bow I was
missing a piece I just didn't know what
piece I was missing I was missing this
plank of wood and now it all makes sense
because the message that I'm missing is
the message in the bottle and this isn't
the place that I need that I need it
over in the other place so I need the
message in the bottle because I bet the
message in the bottle has the recipe for
the soup that's good intelligible to do
that so that was easy to overlook but I
do I did kind of blame myself for that
one that was a little stupid on my part
I just didn't spastically click
everything that I possibly could so
welcome back to Fran though everybody
come on there we go
now I can use the knife to cut that down
get exactly what I need and it'll
probably make me use the tweezers to get
it out of the bottle which is another
thing that I need which is another
reason see it's like it's like
everything doesn't make sense until I
get the little thing left that I need so
that's exactly why why was that
necessary
that burned why there's no fire okay
okay then maybe this got it easy enough
I guess the paper that's so exciting
that's why I need the tweezers not just
to get out of the bottle I guess examine
revealing the true soul the world hides
the truth from you work your soul
through life and you will understand the
purpose of this act if you try to
corrupt this essence your soul will be
hidden and never see the face of truth
to destroy an impure soul or give
freedom to those who are trapped you
will need blood from the executor of the
ritual five black candles ashes to form
a pentagram a blue bloomed moonlight
Rose salt-and-pepper hair of the person
you want to be which draw a pentagram
with the ashes inside the black and
white square put a lighted black candle
on every point of the pentagram fill
cauldron with water put the other
elements in it boil pour over the person
you want to be which repeat these words
while you walk around the pentagram
aren't an air errand or your big boy if
you're Namib you're here gone to be in a
year grandma beg my all my did dima go
off me every year it is now deb am omeg
boo boo Barry my name is now oh if you
play that backward you get a special
message okay so I got almost everything
on the list except blood to the executor
which I believe is me and then hear from
the person I want to be witch so I got
to find hair of theirs and then put
everything else in the pot beside we put
everything in the pot besides fill the
cauldron I want to put the other melts
in it which is law all of this I'm
pretty sure so I need to find a way to
get all of that but I bet on their
pillow is where it would make sense that
there would be and that's why this is
here oh I need to put the ashes first
put the ashes just like that good just
don't walk over it okay so the candles
are there so I bet I can get hair from a
pillow and I'm pretty sure love the
executor would be me I'm just just
guessing here so I'm
it's gotta be on her pillows it's gotta
be that that is the only thing that
makes sense maybe rush you up maybe I
can use the broom to sweep up something
there's got to be a way to get here
there's got to be like a brush or
something in the makeup kit or something
around here and stuff I guess I'll be
very girly when I grow up there's gotta
be something here I'm very close I'm
very close okay so maybe let me just get
this out of the way I'm pretty sure that
I need to take this and retype it up so
that they know exactly what they're
gonna do so this is me being a sneaky
young little girl and this is going to
fool them because apparently they
haven't been staring at the spell for
years and years and know exactly what it
says hair from your head oh so that's
how I'm gonna get their hair that it
seems pretty obvious I mean hair from
your head doesn't make a lot of sense
but hey it is what it is so okay I have
all of that I can't believe they're
trusting me to just make this but oh
well you know what whatever so once I
get that I'm going to have that and then
I need to put my blood into the pond and
then that's probably the last thing that
I need I can bring it all to a boil I
can call oh hi Fran there are all the
materials you need have you studied the
ritual yes but I'll need more time I
can't remember all the words I learned
them fast let him know when you're ready
Oh God
oh no what's in them
the bag girl I think you'll need help
getting rid of this bag for you but I
may need it no you don't trust me if we
want to get out of here this bag must
discipline
that's not your voice a little bit of
rocky bye thank you okay so he's not
even leaving me the choice in this so I
imagine that was the head of the virgin
I guess it better not have been the cat
that's all I gotta say about that let me
just pop outside to see if there's
anything okay
so there's obviously nothing out here
I'm pretty sure I know what I need what
I need is to put everything into this
bucket so salt and pepper blue moonlight
rose and then my own blood that should
be everything kept leave salt pepper as
part of this why that in there blue moon
rose boink goodbye blue rose in the pot
now and then a little bit of my own the
blood oh that's so sad
okay so now I got that that hurts but
now I have my lord use on that okay so
there goes my blood I hope it tastes
good tralala Lala okay so I don't need
the knife anymore but I have the knife
okay so that should be everything blood
from the executor salt and pepper
bloomin rolls in there draw a pentagram
put a lighted black candle on every
point fill cauldron put the other
elements boil pour over the person you
want to be which repeat these words
while you walk around the pentagram
all right I don't know exactly how I'm
gonna be doing this but I guess I got
let me see what does Luke where's there
left there are some missing ingredients
like the hair so I need to show them the
thing of the hair so I can get their
hair then I'll be able to know do I need
to light the candles put a light again
so I need to light the kids use this on
the candles do a ski ok so there's those
are all lit the pots boiling
I just need their hair so I need to show
them the thing then I'll be able to do
what I need to do okay so if I show them
this tampered bad recipe look ladies
there's something missing I couldn't
find your hair in the bag but look for
yourself it's written down here in the
recipe that's true so I got there okay
you know what I'm ready okay so now that
I got the hair I put that in the pot I
wait for them they're probably gonna
come over automatically and then they
still trust me dark hair from the twins
head okay got it
Goti okay so put that in there now the
hair good okay that should be everything
right I should show the girls the potion
is ready I made the most incredible
magic potion in the world I don't know
about that maybe I should examine the
words I want a big ability okay good
enough probably I'll probably be fine I
mean don't they know that they have to
drink it that's part of the recipe that
they know but I have to pour it over
them I guess and let me just
double-check this because this doesn't
seem
or over the person you want to be which
oh I don't need them to be on the
pentagram I suppose so if I just use
this on them and say the words
everything is ready let's go to the
kitchen oh they're gonna go okay let's
go
lot of dah dah dah dah dah well I mean I
would have thought that they would have
used my cat if they got all the
ingredients that's so if I please sit
down and close your eyes ladies why are
they trusting me with this it's not okay
okay the words are I hope I don't have
to remember that all right here we go
they know they have to drink it it's
there it's a recipe and now I'll say the
words this is a 10 year old walking
around a circle with my cats wait a
second is not the right spell oh boy
that looks interesting
Oh
oh okay all right then that was easier
than I thought what have they done oh my
goodness is not right no joke the key
now I can free my dear kitty I'm nervous
oh all right then why did I have the
baking soda why did I have the baking
soda baking powder to make soft dough
bigger worth some of these just red
herrings like the the broom and the
thing why I don't know that kid he
better be there I'm alive that kid he
better be up there and alive and fine
because otherwise kitty oh you're fine
okay good
oh goody goody goody goody you're free
kitty
what is it friend open the cage I can't
the key doesn't fit
did you see another keyhole somewhere
yeah I did I actually remember it it was
in that it was in their room I'll be
waiting oh yeah I remember who's above
their mirror in the room at least that's
the only keyhole that I can distinctly
remember there is a keyhole up there I
can't believe I remember that one okay
wait
possible I'm good at puzzles I don't
know what I'm doing what am i doing oh
it's a dragging okay wait what exactly
am I trying to do what's wait I don't
know what the end goal is huh wait a
minute what I guess I have to open this
thing but how well I mean there aren't
exactly any instructions here how do I
know exactly what I'm doing
oh okay the gear I thought those gears
were fixed points oh okay that that
makes more sense okay so I have the
gears but apparently that gear position
did not work okay this one can't be
moved obviously okay so all these all
these are gears okay that makes a lot
more sense okay now I got it
who's gonna take me well this is fastest
oh well that's so weird safe what is
this two skeletons
mandra's thing yes something tells me
those two oh my god
sister promised week Clara and me
abouhalima
promise to revenge the unfair destiny it
Ward decided for us it's word was the
word that was in the bottom dungeons of
the insane asylum with blood and tears
we promised that we will kill him and
bring our bodies back we won't stand
this any longer even though we are
sisters we hate each other and we will
always hate each other nothing will ever
change that
but now with our bodies attached to each
other we can't complete our task the
strongest will live forever and the
weakest will die okay but this this girl
had duo teen as well but do routine was
scratched off and it's another chemical
that's in there so she must have also
been in the asylum but then again all
this doesn't seem like it'd be weird
it'd be real okay
mother must die
all right who's it word girls are very
strange I wonder why they hate each
other so much - a doll must be really
old doll also quite girly I guess it's
early I guess it's because they played
with it a lot my toys are also a bit
dirty I miss playing with my dollhouse
that's so pink and blue they did
anyway I got the key enough looking at
that that is so weird
so like now I'm to the point where I'm
starting to question exactly what's real
and what's not cuz obviously or it seems
obviously this is not real but also it
could be a ten-year-olds imaginative
interpretation after her mind is rattled
with drugs oh man I think this is the
key it worked my dear kitty it worked
come out let me hug you
yay oh it's a tearful reunion I hope it
doesn't go bad oh oh oh it's such a cute
kitty how can this go wrong that's all I
can think oh this feels so good I'm free
Fran my good friend you're free my dear
now it's time to go home
yes let's go ok we need to get home
kitty I hope the way back home isn't far
I hope so too Fran we can do this
together I can help you ok cool mr.
midnight do you have any ideas on how to
get out of this place I'm sorry I don't
maybe somebody else has some ideas like
a froggy FRU maybe the baby's in here
whoa that's different
Oh sleeping doll would you please sing
for me that's a weird request you don't
want to that's ok I can see for myself
why is there a big old tool there
there's a 2 there and it was a 2 also
inside the mirror
stop letting yourself kitty-kat not
appropriate you're uh you have an
audience people are watching oh hey
kitty ok so there's bound to be
something else but let me just see
because there was a
I don't know if that's just a common
theme or if I just look at that there's
a - right there on their chest or on the
dolls chest so I don't know if that
actually means something but okay so
there's got to be a way down here but
the only other person in here to ask is
mr. froggy outside this window I did it
sir so the girls are gone I want to do
that too sir I finally found my kidney I
just want to go home now and be with
Aunt Grace I thought you could help us
get out of here let me think about it
don't leave us yet please ah mouldable
you say baking powder to make soft dough
bigger and beautiful a little
ten-year-old would probably think that
this would be able to take this toad it
may help but you are all slimy and soft
like dough in the ten-year-old I'm
really big I feel so big and gorgeous
right let's go come on mr. midnight sure
friend I only have one complaint that
giant toad is staring at me
what are you talking about he wants to
help us that's all all right if he tries
anything I will scratch him that's okay
but try not to hurt him so much while
we're sitting on him the water is deep
and we don't know what kind of creatures
are in there if we fall in the water we
could hi kitty
oh I promise I won't scratch but
let's go hey girl
before we go I forgot to give you
something I saw you in this picture so I
thought he was yours oh he found the
picture Thank You mr. toad and this book
will will lead to Leon who's Leo Oh toad
you found my family photo
thank you very much I thought I'd lost
it forever but the book is not mine
oh well take the book and yeah it always
helped me to read
he has many pictures Wow thank you
life lessons from mr. toad I like the
pictures well let's go now yeah here we
go hold on Oh God that does not look as
fun as I thought it'd be why do you have
to shout the entire time we're swimming
thanks mr. toad nonetheless I appreciate
your efforts really is helpful for me oh
oh it's Frogger is this claymation oh
that's amazing
I love claymation okay so do I I know
what I gotta do and I can get an
achievement if I do this right okay so
log quick moves here going going going
going done okay good I get to do it
again I was hoping come on come on come
on come on huh okay I gotta wait for the
next one because this one's not gonna do
good I love the claymation style that's
actually really cool Oh perfect exactly
what I need to do her bit okay it's
gonna be more
this is really cool legitimately this is
like oh whoops all right sorry didn't
mean to do that I hope I don't have
limited lives on this this is
legitimately really cool if this is
actually claymation I would be very
impressed it looks like it but you never
know they could be all that was my ride
I'm a frog there we go okay hey toad on
board I got an achievement I'm doing it
I'm not getting all the achievements I
know that for damn sure but I'm doing
pretty good
Thank You mr. toad you OD wait is he a
toad or a frog well he must be a frog
plant no toads frogs like water more I
don't know here we are
jump off me now let's go kitty Thank You
mr. toady froggy well now it's time to
go home I hope you find your family
Susur soon certo certo well goodbye sir
and thank you for the ride and kitty
didn't have to scratch her eyes out
friend what should we do now find the
way back home kitty do you see the sky
it's dawn and really soon all the scary
things will disappear oh we're almost
done I guess I'm so hungry and sleepy
I'm gonna go home now
me too kitty we'll find the way I'll do
my best to help you my dear let's go
Oh kitty what will be the first thing
you do want to get home I think I would
like the same mom man I bet people don't
picture me as a ten year old girl right
now the voice is little I forgot now I
can take the pills with recklessly
sir are you the curious insects that
gets stuck there sleeping maybe they're
not
well I hope they have their hair comb
maybe they do maybe they don't
oh hello hi oh dear a baby skeleton I
guess they didn't make it in time good
night and sweet dreams well that's
lovely wait what is that is that
something there what is that okay anyway
crossing away we go oh dear this bridge
looks pretty scary Oh Fran come on we
have to go home there is no time to be
afraid now yes but I'm a bit afraid of
heights um I can do first all right then
you can follow me are we gonna get
separated all right kitty you're so
sweet I'll be right behind you okay oh
this is not good not good not good it's
gonna fall it's gonna fall gonna fall
gonna fall Oh kitty come on Fran come on
friend let's go I'm waiting for you
friend wait at least we're together I
think he waved by as we fell into the
abyss thanks buddy
oh my dear I can't hold it anymore I
don't want to die oh no oh oh you won't
die my friend come on you can do it jump
I I'd love to
alright here I go hippy
I got you oh no you don't owe a kitty
doesn't have opposable thumbs I really
thought he had me Oh No oh sweet kitty
oh sweet don't be afraid Fran we always
fall and after the pain we will rise oh
dear Aunt Grace don't ever leave me
don't cry my little girl your heart is
pure but your mind is torment you have
to stay and walk your own path please
Aunt Grace why won't you to take me out
of here please you'll just leave me all
alone like my mother and father did
I'm sorry my dear friend you will soon
understand Aunt Grace no don't go please
please
Oh crying whoa hey friend it's time for
your new medicine
Oh oh gosh that's not good so I imagine
this whole time I've actually still been
in the asylum
oh it's daylight oh oh oh no all the
France clothes are scattered about
Oh what happened will a my friend where
are you now I play as a kitty rule Oh
adieu please the kitty oh look at my
little kitties moths these are friends
stalking this is what a friend shoots
sorry that sounded gross no nothing
about that not gonna pause that okay
friends okay so that's all the time I
have for this episode is spinning very
weird but it's broad daylight out and I
don't know what that's is in the
background maybe we're all seeing this
from a cat's perspective now like oh
that log has a face on it I did not
notice that hello ah what an ugly tree I
scratch you evil thing what are you
talking about friend my darling is that
you it it can't be what is it my dear
what is it my dear of course it's me who
else would it be friend you are three
done don't be silly help me get up Oh
friend wait just a second where are my
hands why can't I move I'm telling you
my dear you have become a tree what but
how
oh my dear this this was the end of the
line the big monster did this I know it
kitty he won't let us go home I hope he
won't come back
he was very scary he always comes back
I think I remember him from that night
that night mom and dad died kitty I
don't want to talk about it I just want
to go home but you were a tree my friend
a tree I can't carry you all the way
back home besides I'm not sure where we
are either am I gonna die Kitty tell me
please don't say that friend don't leave
me but I feel so weak oh whoa Kol cake
okay hey grandma poss Q Holliday the
Joker card Hey are they speaking in the
spell language sounds like gibberish to
me be careful sir why are you attacking
me could you please tell me where I am
sir ha stop it I'll scratch you
hollering what are they saying
oh my kitty why is this happening to us
ha ha stop attacking me please I mean no
harm
Halla ignorantiy kitty help me find my
purse please maybe I can do something
about this I'll see what I can do friend
hello stop attacking my friend Garrett
oh is that all on them say about that I
can't really understand what you singing
stop attacking my friend ok so I got to
find the purse ok where is the purse I'm
guessing it's in the other way over
there I have no idea but you remember my
mother's purse
well that one I'll be right back
idea okay what about this one over here
you haven't said much I don't even
remember the voices that I assigned to
these guys
an old vegetable sitting on a boat that
also flew I I do remember that things
are gonna get a little weird around here
okay there's the purse
oh that was handy oh okay maybe I could
use one of these crystals to jam the
gears I have a stone can I use there we
go okay I needed to use the crystal with
that okay so now it should stay and
shouldn't be able to go back got the
purse I got the purse only become on the
best become a big LR I can't even speak
it but I'm a kitty so it's amazing that
I can speak at all okay so now Oh Fran
Fran Oh Fran my darling I got the purse
that's amazing you are the best mr.
midnight is the best now show the sir
who is attacking me my family picture
maybe he understands what a human is
well I really hope he does okey-dokey
then
what is it but first what is this
mysterious book I can't read it because
my cat pass get alta okay find that oh
hello well huh were you taking me sir
vegetable okay I guess we're gonna go
fly off into the distance then they want
to help you friend I can feel it okay oh
don't be afraid my friend
kitty stop them please don't leave me I
will be right here with you I guess I
don't know maybe I should stop shouting
out their gibberish because it doesn't
make any sense to me either
but it's important for the story so I
will still narrate that's basically all
I'm doing here
Chapter three vegetative state oh good
we're starting off with a pun always
best when we start off with a pun like
every conversation with Wade ever oh
hello
hi it's been Bahaman tell us Ben er oh
it's still the little guy hallo
oh you smell it Perry Girish guy in
baton you'll feel I feel like I'm
playing The Sims again doors get er oh
okay bye
yes please go away welcome creature my
name is Xia do you speak human oh my
goodness yes finally words I understand
my good friend Ryan told me that you
showed him an illustration with four
humans and a cat
I assume you are one of them the little
guy er
please forgive my good friend if he
scared you we have never seen a woman
looking like a tree before yes let me
explain it to you even though I don't
think I can fully explain it anything no
need to speak my child the speed will
show me everything bear baby bear boo
okay then this is a little weird oh I
will admit
I've heard many a story from a
ten-year-old going on and on but this is
really intricate let me see
you are good no doubt about that seeker
of truth very common of the bow family
ah
your name is fraud you are the girl with
a path he owned for life
I see great Louvre towards this little
createrra standing next to you I cannot
protect or of the GAR tears
interesting yeah why does everybody know
about me your friend be quiet it's a
long story I see something else the sea
doesn't heed a anything I see a world
nobody should see nobody except for
Warner what do you mean by except for
one you mean the monster you are not
supposed to be here Fran that is the
only thing I can tell you my child
I understand but can you help me then we
can't let you leave now it's too
dangerous for us well aren't you
greeting you should have never have been
aware of hiring in this sentence there
must be a way that am i dead or
something what do you mean by that you
know when you no longer exist besides
it's not normal to be a tree I must be
dead death is nothing more than the
absence of okay once you can't feel you
die even if your body still works
I still feel love for my kitty I can't
be dead please help me little cat come
closer let me see you what is your
nominee
my new miss mr. midnight that is indeed
a very pretty name do you think France
should go back home eh yes I do sir
oh you're a man never mind then show us
the way back home I implore you
ah I have a question are you the king
for some reason I assumed you were the
Queen the king of thirst
oh what an honor your highness by the
way I like your leaves they are pretty
King sir please will you help me
why is this need of you to go home eh so
rot the seed told me your story you
don't have much to go back to you there
are many reasons sir but the most
important is my aunt she will protect me
I want to feel that somebody cares about
me I feel confused almost all the time
and I want to be some Play Doh ah shut
up I just want to go home please
I will lead you to the door that will
take you home eh but it's your home -
the water
order.we long about that later fast
cranberry right you might be able to
talk and walk yes sir that would be very
great I'm afraid I won't be able to
bring your body back only the great
wizard oh my god are we in the Land of
Oz but we'll talk more about him after
the procedure and cranberries you must
understand darling
how will I ever understand your language
he is Froude don't mind the spit think
of it as a delicious cranberry your ears
and tongue will be able to understand or
something maybe but not your eyes that
means you won't be able to read yeah
don't worry about that I can always ask
excuse me do you understand oh shoot me
you understand what I say human lady yes
I do and you sound so kind this is
incredible did you understand my kitty
I didn't your highness I demand one food
for myself you don't need that fruit mr.
midnight cranberries are for humans in
trees our land is a based on fragrances
it challenged yo see everything is your
own world very soon no doubt about that
you'll do fine Kitty and sir do you know
why I became a tree to give you answers
or tell you anything for that matter I'm
not gonna do much I'm going to sit here
and thinking about cranberry Bauer
Cypress are you afraid of heights
Ben tonight why I did fall and became a
tree Oh
hi where are you taking me what are you
gonna do to me
if you are I'll be waiting for you
friend I love you okay thank God that
bugs got sexy legs if it's weirding me
out
okay then little bizarre I mean
everything is very bizarre but that was
a little bizarre okay thank you
oh hi is this the neverending stalo good
day my name is blonde Tris and I'm your
doctor day at your humble service
are you the amend indicate
Wow amazing what a huge beautiful fluffy
thing excuse me I'm sorry it's just that
I've never seen anything like you before
I'm still trying to understand that all
this is regula my name is fran i'm a
human girl I mean human the king sent me
here to get some arms and legs so I can
go home I think I can get you a pair of
legs Oh have to travel a little bit
further in order to fix that are you
ready to enter the power of the beast
what beast me the Beast let's go okay
fine then this is so interesting like
it's bizarre and weird but for some
reason I'm like really into it right now
I have no idea what's going on oh okay
have fun drowning oh yeah wow this place
is so beautiful and peaceful I wish I
could be here forever and I guess I will
without arms and legs thank you
this is my home as well oh the spirit of
the grave velakis created it don't worry
you don't know him and that's the pure
water in the whole universe or at least
up here I don't know where it come from
oh wow that sounds amazing or something
see when do we start so when do I get my
arms and legs back never
oh we wait until the water purified the
earth in the meantime we can talk
alright so who's velakis and how's the
weather
haven't you heard about the five
realities no he's the king in the first
reality time ago he was at war with the
darkness one day he fell or something I
don't know
he felt so badly his heart was broken he
was all alone
sadness filled its soul but it came to
its erster and his brother made this
water paint that is why it's so pure
it's very long story
wow that sounds grand I think I didn't
follow anything I'm ten and also I'm a
tree I mean I didn't know that about
other realities I'm just gonna believe
you on this one you are here what
brought you to its earth stop my Kitty
and I we're on our way back home
and then we were fighting the darkness I
guess and we fell a long way and I'm so
pure and now I'm in here
maybe I'm black of that I'm so happy to
see him and hug him again then we fell
the big monster that follows me did this
he broke the bridge he wants to be dead
I think I prefer not to talk about this
well you know we got nothing to do but
talk so it might as well talk about
something but sir doctor do you know why
I became a tree that's kind of the
biggest mystery here and I'm weirded out
by why I'm accepting it so much wrong
you did this in order to keep those have
alive don't ask me why I have no idea
I'm just making this up as I go along
so you took only dish to maintain enough
treasured memory with you it is actually
the first time I've seen a human using a
tree and Christmas but it's dangerous
damn you yeah it makes our man
vulnerable I don't even know where this
is but it's pure oh sorry is device I'm
having fun with that voice I did this to
myself Wow
but pelant rest' sir I didn't understand
any of that because I'm 10 how I didn't
know I was doing anything again 10 on a
lot of drugs lots of drugs you really
didn't know what you want to win I see
well you must be a demon when you travel
to assert you opened a door between your
realities an hour
this made a fancy world and with this
door open
unexpected creatures can also enter our
reality probably I don't know something
fell I guess five reality I don't know
I'm getting mixed up now and if that
happens the balance will be tainted but
I mean oh something like I'll become
evil and there is all their world who
likes a pause in the second reality here
the monster the terrible blacks are now
racist
oh oh just thinking about it makes me
pee in my ass I'm just paying I'll stop
it I'll send you to their Beth don't be
sad doctor I'm very sorry for what I did
whatever I did I didn't know why I did
it for my own survival I ruined all of
your existence sorry
Oh little girl you're so nice and you
don't have anything to be sorry for
I do because I'm about to end your girls
thank you very special well let's
concentrate on your I'll believe no okay
doctor I still don't have them yet I've
been sitting in this water a long time
oh you mean you could have said that at
any time well that would have been
awfully nice of you gonna fall oh how do
you feel I ran from a theft ah wow I
feel like a beautiful tree
I have Levy's oh no I'm not gonna talk
like her him King I'm glad you liked it
I told you we would fit here this water
is metal it's in it there
anything do you think I could fix my
mommy and daddy
what do you mean fix them what's wrong
with them nothing doctor thank you very
much for helping me also they're dead
you're the best doctor I've ever had and
I haven't had many cousin ten and you
were fluffy and beautiful
I had another doctor before oh I did
have another doctor he was evil his name
was dr. dear but he was an evil old man
Harry said that oh man
maybe he was just following the rules
that everyone should do it never quit oh
here we are again so Zach king what an
ass is substantial ah you've become
thank you again doctor your accent is a
little heavy so I didn't actually
understand anything I was delirious from
being turned into a tree but you have to
meet my kitty someday that would be
lovely
and I'll try to work on my movie goodbye
okay bye
front flying powers it's real thing
probably you fluffy Here I am Fran my
dear you've got leaves on your head
how pretty let me see ah
what a great ass of liber8 you've become
you mean a third of senators dance at
night
Thank You King sir the doctor is
incredible and hard to understand he
made magic with the water even though he
didn't really do anything and he could
have sent those words a lot sooner
oh well but he was sad he told me many
things but I don't quite understand how
I ruined all of your lives
don't worry philosophers will be funny I
know the reasons we have some problems
to solve but that's nothing if you worry
about let's talk about how you can go
back home right yes please
you said something about a great wizard
yes the great Wizard of Oz is the only
one who can bring your home Bodhi back
honey as a stone A's that can open a the
door a that will lead you home a sir are
you putting more inflections on things
intentionally where's the wizard but
stones I don't get any of this you
haven't even gone outside his castle and
you want and FFP
yes I haven't left in 50 years but
that's beside the point
that's the passion I was talking about
have patience ride on another fruit from
my mouth the great wizard lives in the
great mountain quarter quarter quarter
quarter quarter in last one but we
haven't seen him for a while now find
him and everything would be just fine
well haven't you tried to find the great
wizard yourself and what was his name
again
what mounted did live and it's not in
part we don't mean to its logical just
shut up and stop questioning everything
you see you we don't need a wizard for
magical prepare potion made fruit come
out of my mouth
so we then mode valuable to ask us to
protect the stairs and everything there
I see
so this sounds are like keys and where
is this mountain you said pose the name
and then come on
what are your facts have to ask around
its farms mind I'll be here thinking
about things you go on I have to go
goodbye forever
I'll be back in time to help you with
the door good bye have a great day
Lister good luck trying to three with it
okay
Wow did you see that huge fluffy
creature kitty that's Paul Andres he
fixed me I think yes it's certainly very
fluffy oh I forgot here's your purse
yeah I got my purse back I wonder if
there's anything stolen oh thank you
kitty did you see my pills anywhere I
don't think so
maybe they are on the other side of the
lake next to your clothes well we have
other things to do anyway we have to
find a wizard yes the King said
something about a mountain - can't
remember the name he didn't seem very
decisive about it the ass Mountain Kurd
Mountain caught caught the great wizard
lives there let's go alrighty then
you told me that we have to find
Mountain cotrim and the great wizard
okay so I already told you that okay so
I have things Oh God
I found myself hunting the truth but
finding the unexpected I found what my
senses could not show me I found the
truth that relays silently in the
unknown them well that's interesting
these actual poems my name is Leon
I'm currently 92 years old and living
alone in a little house far away from
the city I have to admit I never was
fond of jewelry houses or clothing since
childhood I always talk to animals
plants and insects and even though I
never got to response I never quit if
you're reading this maybe it's because
you're looking for answers maybe you can
see things that others can't where you
can feel what others avoid you can
listen to the silence and become one
with everything
okay it's yes I definitely can that
sounds a lot like me oh hey
December 17th I can't stop it I can't
control they see the black shadows
everywhere the blood the messages the
screaming all the pain I can't figure
out why this is happening to me yes I
can see the black shadows Oh cry because
it hurts
I had a vision I'm still breathing fear
I feel at war with my own mind one of
the shadows came down from the sky I
thought it was an angel it's his name
it's name is Reem or Prince of Darkness
from the fifth reality it talked to me
played with me and showed me all the
terrors it told me that I was the key to
its existence inside my head the stone
of wisdom inside my head maybe this is
the book of the great wizard
great wizard I can see myself around the
others the other me tell me lies talks
about all my all the pain and suffering
in my life the other me he wants me to
commit suicide he smiles while
pronouncing the words kill yourself and
I have tried hypnotized by his words but
there's always something saving me at
the end it must be the love to live I
meet a shadow for the first time it
talked to me
Kamala's the race is called the Kamala's
they hunt weakness in pain I asked it
about the possession of human bodies in
it said we were born and feed from fear
and the uncontrolled illness of human
mind we are invisible to them but our
existence grabs every single living cell
in their body until the very end after
that has started raining and it walked
away from me leaving a black oily path
after it I believe the water may purify
them after seeing the Kamala's reacting
to water I thought of trying the little
experiment last night I encountered
something amazing the Kamala's
transformed into something a new kind of
creature when exposed to water the
metamorphosis was painful to watch after
the terrible screaming the Kamala's
calmed down and started to cry on the
ground it felt like the pain was
disappearing after a few minutes a
bright and peaceful being was rising in
front of me it felt like the bright
creature could read my mind
I thank you for waking me up I was
suffering I must go where I belong
it first awaits all the locusts must go
there after waking up if you wish to see
me the light come with me you have the
key it said I didn't answer after a
while it faded away I was reading my
writings to see if I'm missing something
I could recall REME or from the fifth
reality if there is a fifth reality
there must be at least four more I was
thinking that if thirst I may not be a
city in this world but a reality of by
itself I wish all the answers came to me
I deeply regret the fact that I didn't
accept the blackest invitation since I
saw the velakis I kept seeing this
diagram spinning in my head in a single
sentence time is the rhythm of your
perception
I got a visit from my son Brian I told
them about the things I've seen but he
didn't want to hear and left I don't
blame him I understand that the reality
presented before my eyes is invisible to
most people I wish I could find a friend
just like me
because my son he thinks I'm insane
that's sad my body and mind of being
beginning to understand the pattern life
becomes quite easy to control when you
cut all social laws and only apply our
reality laws because they are not only
laws but also behaviors chemical
behaviors natural laws without those
behaviors without those laws we wouldn't
exist
sometimes I wish to be a leaf on the
ground calm Wow last night after the
storm a huge creature visited mud guard
grunting weirdly through the night sky
was bizarre and he disappeared I found a
strange bottle with a pink liquid inside
in the same spot the creature landed I
can't fully understand the contents of
the bottle I have found red blood cells
in it and bacteria not yet recognized
the bacteria seems to be rid of the
unusual behaviors in any kind of living
creature I poured some of the pink
liquid on the dying plan and it bloomed
after a few minutes I cut my finger to
test the liquid with human tissue and it
cured it after a few seconds this
bacteria may work his platelets and
white blood cells but at a very high
speed did they know about bacteria back
in 1876 oh uh not time to question man I
dream of a thousand black cats
surrounding my house big yellow eyes
staring at me sleep beings in and
thirsty are buried from roots to giant
insects roots are the very first in this
reality insects came later I learned the
language in numerology dang whoa
alphabet great volakis than the
beginning of the first reality how much
is there here creation of great velakis
beginning in a thirst it feels like you
coming
what you can't understand on earth its
where leaves sing while falling off tree
and water whispers its wisdom when you
drink it Pandora creation of the five
realms of essential existence fr EE
besides in the human world third reality
Earth Mars and Jupiter consciousness
practices of will send air Siddi at the
end of vibration when both ends of the
opposites are the same degree resides in
third and fourth reality death ma bucha
is the end of light
Wow mother but bucha is letting me go I
spent 15 days here in Lukas den and I'm
tired I don't need to hide from pain
anymore because it's part of me it feels
like love is everywhere and everything
I enjoy crying I enjoy laughing I enjoy
being alive no date recorded I'm getting
ready for the journey back home
the bucha send me to the endless limits
of malukas den and I'm waiting for the
Lucifer ends I had to become friends
with them or to be more precise become
one of them Lucifer owns gather in
filaments that's why they look like
they're growing hair and the big faces
mostly for communication purposes and to
scare their predators I hope my body can
survive the journey gravity collects
particles to create new ones it's a
creative force and with creativity
evolution is inevitable and that's the
end drawing to the left looks like an
antenna and that somebody ripped out the
rest of the book but there's a pattern
man that was a ride that was a trippy
ride whoa okay I'm gonna find out I'm
just a little more you hello sexy legs
how you doing
should I call you slags but another
character is already ok sorry I just
want to see what's behind this passage
library of cough that come back and
follow in time and it will be open if
you survive that long what was that last
part
hey aren't you the talking tree I to see
plum juice yes that's me pelant just
gave me arms and legs or the water did
he didn't really do much yes not very
positive that hehe yes but why is the
library closer that's the important
question that I want to know right now
that's logic as the Sun goes around the
second moon of Bethesda we open then I
stand here for the rest of time only
then the real knowledge will be land and
that only happens in fallen winter
remember that oh so you don't learn
anything while you're in summer or
spring you little brats we learn all the
time
I'm very smart I'm learning now that you
like to mask them independence well I'm
curious that's why aren't you being a
little obtuse I guess you're not from
around here I'd be there I hope I feel
soon goodbye okay bye
Thanks sexy legs goodbye now see the
characters that I got to remember here
wow this is a bit scary but it's so
beautiful
jarhead burger okay so I think that's
all the time for this episode I did want
to say before I ended this thing
this is kidding so weird it's take you
so many different directions that I had
no idea that this game was would ever
take like I can't imagine the creative
process but kind writing the story I bet
that in and of itself is a pretty cool
story so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'll get back to this real -
and as always I will see
ready
so the idea is that how can we shut up
all defenses up down